تنضم إلي الآن نورا عريقات،
أستاذة مشاركة في قسم
الدراسات الأفريقية في برنامج
العدالة الجنائية بجامعة رواس نيو
برونزويك، نقدر
وجودك معنا، شكرًا لاستضافتي، لذلك تبدأ
قضية الإبادة الجماعية في جنوب إفريقيا ضد إسرائيل
اليوم في المحكمة الدولية
العدالة مع جنوب أفريقيا التي تتهم
إسرائيل بارتكاب جرائم إبادة جماعية في حرب غزة
وتطلب من المحكمة فرض
إجراءات طارئة لتعليق الحملة العسكرية الإسرائيلية،
وتقول إسرائيل إن هذا أمر فظيع
ومناف
للعقل. ما الذي يمكن أن نتوقعه
من هذه الجلسة في رأيك، وما مدى
أهميتها؟  أن
جنوب أفريقيا هي التي جلبت هذا ضد
إسرائيل المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة، وأعتقد أنها لحظة مهمة بشكل لا يصدق أه
في التاريخ حيث أن
جنوب أفريقيا التي تغلبت على
تاريخها من الأبارتي تقود الآن
غالبية العالم الذي يعارض
حرب إسرائيل أه على
حملة الإبادة الجماعية للفلسطينيين الآن مستمرة منذ أكثر من ثلاثة
أشهر ويقود تلك الأغلبية إلى
العودة للحصول على أه
إجراءات مؤقتة في محكمة
العدل الدولية من أجل إجبار إسرائيل على وقف
حملتها العسكرية لفرض
وقف دائم لإطلاق النار لم يتم
التوصل إليه خلال  مجلس الأمن الدولي
بسبب استخدام أمريكا لحق
النقض فيه متحدية إرادة
أغلبية العالم وتحديدا 153
دولة طالبت بأه بوقف
دائم لإطلاق النار أم تم
تجاوزها بهذا الفيتو والآن ما نراه
في هذا  يعد هذا التحرك إلى محكمة العدل الدولية بمثابة
خطوة لفرض وقف إطلاق النار هذا
وكذلك خطوة لإنهاء الإبادة الجماعية والمساءلة
عنها، وتسمى محكمة العدل الدولية أيضًا
بالمحكمة العالمية وهي أعلى
هيئة قانونية تابعة للأمم المتحدة للتعامل مع
مثل هذه النزاعات ولكنها لديها  لا توجد
سلطة إنفاذ وهذا يعني بالطبع
حتى لو وجدت بالنسبة لجنوب أفريقيا أنها
لا تستطيع إنفاذ تلك النتيجة، لذا فإن ما تم
تحقيقه
جيدًا تمامًا هو أن محكمة العدل الدولية التي تعد
جهازًا رئيسيًا للأمم المتحدة هي
المحكمة الوحيدة التي يمكنها أه تسوية
النزاعات بين الدول وهنا
الخلاف حول اتفاقية الإبادة الجماعية
تزعم جنوب أفريقيا أن إسرائيل
ارتكبت إبادة جماعية و/أو فشلت في
منع الإبادة الجماعية، يوثق ذلك في
بيان من 84 صفحة يحتوي على 30 صفحة
من تفاصيل الأفعال مثل أه
الحرب على الأطفال الآن مقتل 9600 طفل
في ثلاث  أشهر بمعدل مائة
كل يوم ما وصفه الأمن العام أم
الأمين العام للأمم المتحدة
أنطونيو جوز الآن غزة بأنها
مقبرة أه للأطفال ردا على ذلك
إسرائيل تقول أن هذه مجرد
نتيجة شنيعة للحرب وأعتقد هنا
هؤلاء  إن الآثار المترتبة على ذلك ليست
آثارًا على الفلسطينيين وإسرائيل فحسب،
بل إنها تؤثر أيضًا على مستقبل
العالم. إذا تمكنت إسرائيل بالفعل من ارتكاب
إبادة جماعية ووصفتها بأنها مجرد حرب أو
استثناء، فإن بقية العالم
معرض لضرر شديد وخطر شديد، لذلك حتى لو قررت
المحكمة الدولية  لا يمكن للعدالة أن
تفرض وقفًا فوريًا
لإطلاق النار لمنع إسرائيل من
مواصلة الإبادة الجماعية من خلال
آلية إنفاذ، فهي لا تزال ترسل
إشارة مهمة للغاية بالنسبة
للمبتدئين، فهي تواصل عزل
الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل سياسيًا على
المسرح العالمي، والأهم من ذلك أنها تواصل عزل الولايات المتحدة وإسرائيل سياسيًا على المسرح العالمي.
يخول الدول الأخرى المستعدة
لمحاسبة إسرائيل محاكمة
مجرمي الحرب الإسرائيليين أمام
محاكمها الوطنية بموجب الولاية القضائية
العالمية وكذلك
فرض المقاطعة وكذلك
الامتناع عن الاستمرار في بيع الأسلحة
لإسرائيل.  كثيرًا
لانضمامك إلينا، نقدر
ذلك، شكرًا لاستضافتي